vous êtes là en France vous êtes la
honte de Paris on a mis deux siècles à
faire de Paris la plus belle ville du
monde en demandant vous en avez fait la
poubelle du monde c'est à soi-même c'est
ma liberté d'expression c'est honteux
vous détruisez Paris
alors j'ai l'homme qui a été interpellé
enfin qui a interpellé mais avec qui
veut la mère de Paris n'était pas un
parfait inconnu c'est Léo nicollion il a
été journaliste
qui a interpellé Macron tu sais en
traversant la rue un jour tu te souviens
pas une petite notoriété dans les oui
c'est ça d'accord
[Rires]
qu'il aurait été condamné en Arménie
voilà et pour menace de mort sur Charles
Aznavour attention
c'est magnifique ce qu'ils ont fait des
espaces verts partout c'est très joli et
Paris c'est des plots jaunes
dégueulasses en plein préparation et
tout Bastille j'y suis allé cet immonde
je veux bien qu'elle fasse des choses
pour l'écologie j'ai aucun souci avec ça
mais tout ce qui est fait elle est c'est
des boulots qui sont mis en jaune comme
ça c'est dégueulasse
c'est très très sale c'est très très
Neuilly-sur-Seine ils ont mis des
espèces de beaux bac avec
des espaces verts enfin ouais c'est
triste elle a vraiment abîmé Paris alors
quand c'est de quoi adora c'est bon je
peux te dire c'est pas
pareils alors si c'est mais je sais pas
conseillers municipaux c'est la fameuse
loi PLM Paris Lyon
et puis que malheureusement pour des
raisons qu'on ignore les autres partis
n'ont jamais envoyé quelqu'un de très
fort en face ça n'a jamais été le cas ça
a toujours été des gens qui étaient pas
très connu depuis Chirac on a pas une
personne qui se présente
il y en a à peine un tiers qui votent
comment tu veux changer elle se remerge
jusqu'à la fin de séjour
à Paris intra-muros et en plus Paris est
super endetté on le dit pas mais il y a
la dette de Paris qui a faillette mettre
mise sous tutelle et on est super
endettés
je ne la défends pas spécifiquement et
je vais expliquer pourquoi j'ai voté
pour elle en plus
[Musique]
j'ai voté pour elle parce que j'estime
qu'il n'y a strictement perte moi je
vote toujours et j'estime qu'il n'y a
strictement personne pour qui voter
apparaît à Paris voilà
par défaut dans ce cas là votre pas
parce que moi je vais voter toujours pas
blanc je m'engage après on ne juge ou
pas mais moi je vote pour quelqu'un et
je vois qui apparaît il y avait Bertrand
Delanoë ok c'est très bien
pas pour moi pourquoi alors pourquoi
parce que je trouve qu'elle est malade
et demain il y a le classement du 6 à 13
qui va arriver je te le dis fais gaffe
ce qui s'est passé avec Anne Hidalgo
c'est je pense que c'est le revers en
fait du pouvoir politique et les
politiques doivent accepter qu'il se
fasse qu'il se passerait pour demander
parfois par des gens dans la rue et moi
je pense que Anne Hidalgo elle devrait
pour légitimer son programme
sortir du silence et expliquer pourquoi
elle fait si pourquoi est-ce qu'elle
fait ça et c'est pour ça qu'elle devrait
venir une fois pour toi si pour vous
expliquer et peut-être vous convaincre
peut-être mais à force de se mur comme
ça dans le silence elle en perd toute
crédibilité
par la Mairie de Paris la pollution n'a
pas diminué parce que les voitures sont
totalement à l'arrêt les gens déserté
Paris c'est la première ville c'est la
seule ville d'Europe où les gens et
troisièmement les investissements à part
l'euro dollars les investissements des
étrangers ne viennent plus ils vont à
Londres et record de l'endettement de
Paris